la izquierda latinoamericana desde Cuba
México Colombia Venezuela chile hasta
Perú Argentina y Bolivia celebró El
regreso del izquierdismo a Brasil con la
victoria de Luis Ignacio lulada Silva en
las presidenciales tu Victoria fortalece
la democracia y la integración
latinoamericana mientras el presidente
saliente el ultraderecista Yair
bolsonaro permanente en silencio sus
aliados conservadores en la región
también emitieron sus felicitaciones
anulada Silva saludamos al presidente
electo de Brasil Lula confiamos en
trabajar para un mercosur moderno y
abierto al mundo también en el norte del
continente tanto el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden como el Primer
Ministro de Canadá Justin trudeau
celebraron el triunfo del izquierdista y
el democrático proceso electoral envió
mis felicitaciones a Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva por su elección para hacer el
próximo presidente de Brasil luego de
las elecciones libres justas y creíbles
espero trabajar juntos para continuar la
cooperación entre nuestros dos países en
los próximos meses y años recibimiento
que se extendió hasta Europa entre
mandatarios de izquierda como el jefe de
gobierno español Enhorabuena Lula por tu
Victoria en estas elecciones en las que
Brasil ha decidido apostar por el
progreso y la esperanza o el centrista
francés de Manuel macón y la comisión
europea you laters a Luis Ignacio la
Unión Europea felicita Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva como presidente electo y
felicitamos al tribunal electoral en
particular
en el resto del mundo Rusia Sudáfrica
Kenia Nueva Zelanda o china también se
unieron a los saludos con mensajes
apelando al trabajo conjunto
china está dispuesta a trabajar con el
nuevo gobierno brasileño encabezado por
el señor Lula para promover la
asociación estratégica integral entre
China y Brasil a un nuevo nivel
junto a los líderes políticos los
activistas medioambientales también
celebraron El Triunfo de Lula partidario
de proteger la amazonía brasileña uno de
los temas centrales de la campaña